hello believe nation I made the men t'me
series with the goal to try to hang
around people who've done a lot more
than us who have wisdom and expertise to
share and hopefully the more time we
spend watching the videos and being
around them the more of their mindset
their beliefs or values synching to us
to help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from Sadhguru on being motivated mentor
me said guru I was just thinking about
you and I was going over the story of
your life and what you think your
mission is like do the purpose everybody
tries to find their purpose if you
figure I've been able to articulate to
yourself what it is no I don't have a
purpose and I think it's it's
unnecessary for each individual to have
create or invent their own purpose life
has its purpose our business is to see
how well we can fulfill that that's what
I like about we tie well because so much
about anything that spiritual or
religion applies so much value to the
self as opposed to just experience where
it's already there we are just a piece
of life if this can become a
full-fledged life that's all it is it's
just that because there is no sense of
balance and joy and peacefulness in
people people are trying to find a
purpose and always a god-given purpose
and what makes each individual think
that God is giving you a particular
purpose right it's a large creation you
know
now those consciousness or the physical
purpose like in the way that an ant
serves a purpose in ecosystem
consciousness is our own thing
consciousness is not our own thing
know what I mean in terms of like people
sometimes you know you do your job as a
physical being and that might be your
job
what's the immediate purpose right now
yeah right but that's it so I'm do you
think that are you talking about just a
physical being are you talking about
something else so this is what when
people are looking or when people are in
pursuit of happiness they are trying to
do specific things that they like if
your life is an expression of you
joy then you're not looking at what you
can do you're looking at what is needed
and you do that well I think that's
everybody's business in this world what
is most needed right now if we can do it
joyfully that's all there is I want to
fulfill my women you want to fulfill
your whim and there's a whole lot of
problem we're doing a whole lot of
unnecessary things from the planet
because we're in pursuit of happiness
rather than being an expression of joy
at every point in human life for every
intelligent human being who's willing to
look at their lives with some sense of
openness questions will arise am i his
audio Kate's is coming back to me
questions will arise am I really doing
the right thing
is my life going waste these questions
will arise for every human being
successful are not so successful it
doesn't matter
only for those who are a bit thrilled by
themselves such people won't get
questions they will address this
question on their deathbed for everybody
else with every step questions will come
up is this the way I want to spend my
life because what you considered as life
it's just a brief amount of time if you
are joyful if you're a very joyful and
exuberant human being it's a very brief
life if you're miserable it's a long
life because you have noticed in your
life on a given day if you're very happy
and exuberant 24 hours pass away like
that you're miserable or depressed then
a day seems like a yawn so time is a
very relative experience those who are
successful reasonably joyful questions
will come up because time is just
slipping away life is just slipping away
is this what I want to do this is the
way I want to be
so reinvention becomes a relevant factor
before we reinvent let's understand the
word invent essentially means in its
Latin origins it means to arrive to
arrive means if you are in a haze of
something if you come beyond that that's
generally considered arrival and when we
say an individual the root word for the
individual is indivisible
that means you are not further divisible
you have become an individual but that's
not happened to most of the human beings
on the planet they are still an
accumulation of many things finding
expression if you are sincere enough to
look at yourself and prejudiced looking
if you do you will see what you
considered as myself is a combination of
many influences too many influences your
parentage your genetics your education
your exposure in the world slowly you
have accumulated your persona persona or
personality is a hotchpotch of many
things you can't arrive as an individual
in that this is why it doesn't matter
what kind of personality you have built
there is always a certain sense of lack
of ease in these things because it's an
accumulated concoction
an individual means not further
divisible that means you have become a
being not a person personality is there
to work in the world you need a persona
to face the world but this is an
individual being when I say not further
divisible in the world you do it in so
many ways if you're getting spiritual
you will become an expert in dividing
yourself into many things you will
always hear language like this if you're
doing something if you do it the way you
want it it's you if you're pleasant it's
you suppose you turn nasty you look back
and say that was my ego and people will
go further and say this is my soul that
is my self that is my Atman that is my
Paramatma if there is more than one
within you right now that means you're
either schizophrenic or you're possessed
you either need a psychiatrist or eggs
or cysts you must decide which one
because there is only one here but he
this is taking on many forms as per
convenience the most important thing is
an individual cannot be reinvented but
has to be discovered has to be explored
because personality has been invented by
you this being is not your invention
this is creation and the source of
creation when I say the source of
creation if you ate a banana in the
morning in two hours time
this banana transforms itself into human
form
so the source of creation is throbbing
because one is not in touch with that
people are trying to make up their
personality they're trying to invent
themselves if you want to function at
your highest level you should not invent
yourself you must discover the nature of
vortices these things are happening
because there is no experience of what
this individual is so we are making up
things we make up things by identifying
ourselves with many things that we are
not starting from the body it is obvious
that you were not born like this but you
it's a question were you born like this
you came like this and became this much
now I'm asking are you all natural birth
or did you drop from heaven please hello
all normal birth not a heavenly drop if
your normal birth you were born like
this and now you became like this
obviously the body is an accumulation
the content of your mind is also an
accumulation everything that you have is
an accumulation what is an accumulation
can be yours can never have a be you
what you accumulate you cannot consider
that as myself so fundamentally because
one does not strive because the society
in which you grow up because the
education systems did not make any
effort to connect you with the dimension
of this individual who is not further
divisible you start identifying with
things the moment you took on identity
your mind works only around what you are
identified with there is a very
beautiful situation which occurred in
upward the Emperor his life when he was
very young when he was an infant due to
some political situations he was
separated from his mother for a period
of time because he was separated from
his mother they brought in another woman
who also had a child to nurse at birth
when he was an infant so she had a boy
who was a few months older to up birth
and she breastfed both these children
later on upwards mother came under the
age of 12 12 he was coronated
as the king by the time he was 25 he was
known across the known world as a great
emperor somewhere along the way he gave
a few villages to this boy who was the
son of this lady who breastfed aqua
because akbar felt we drank the milk of
the same mother so both of us are
brothers
so he gave a few villages to his elder
brother but by the time he was 13 that
man lost everything
and again penniless then one day he got
a bright idea he thought my younger
brother has become a great Emperor if I
go to him maybe something will come my
way so he came akbar was deeply
identified with this
we drank milk from the same mother so we
are brothers
so he welcomed them with the Hana that
should be given to an elder brother
and brought him in and kept him in the
court but he is a village dud
who doesn't know one thing from the
other he just looked around at the
things that were happening and outputs
at burrs court at burr had gathered
enormous talent of musicians
mathematicians all kinds of talent he
looked at all this dazed by this then
time to leave was coming then one day he
told aqua see the reason why you are
doing so well here is you got some
really smart people around you if I had
such people around me I would also
become a great emperor especially you
have this Bilbo he is too smart if I had
a man like him with me I would also
build a great Empire Akbar felt very
guilty that his elder brother is feeling
like this he told him if you want you
take verbal with you so this fellow felt
very encouraged and said yes he will
comes with me I will also become a great
Emperor then after called beer bull and
said my elder brother wants you to go
with him you go with him and do whatever
you need to do with him being bull's eye
balls rolled what is he going to do with
this fool then he said my lord why me I
will send my elder brother with your
elder brother and Akbar
also was relieved because he didn't want
to lose babel so he asked this fellow is
it okay if beer bulls elder brother
comes with you the fool thought he beer
bill is so smart is elder brother must
be super smart and he said yes
next day morning is the send-off party
the full assembly of the court he is
leaving the brother el de Braga beer
will walked into the court with the bull
on the rope and upper looked at the
censor what is this he said my lord
you wanted my elder brother to go with
your elder brother
here he is I forgot really angry are you
trying to insult my brother he said no
my lord we drank meat from the same
mother the moment you get identified
with something your intelligence is just
wrapped around this identity it is
because of this identifications not one
many a complex web of identities you
become a person instead of being an
individual a person means a mess there
is no person with clarity a personality
means it's a mess of things so many
things put together hot spots depending
upon what you are exposed to you become
a certain kind of person but we need
this if you have to gather all this
there is something more fundamental
which is the individual the individual
being is there that is why these
accumulations of stacks of accumulations
are possible these accumulations can be
analyzed broken down but the individual
cannot be further broken down it's
indivisible that's why it's an
individual I think for long periods of
time
human societies have suffered this
struggle for survival when you want to
survive your ability to discriminate is
the most important quality otherwise you
don't share why till we create kind of
societies where everybody can survive
this cannot be put to rest so this is
the reason why essence
scientists did not Bank so much on
intellect but on intelligence there's a
distinct difference because probably in
English language there is no words to
describe different aspects of one's
intelligence in Sanskrit language there
are at least eight dimensions of your
intelligence
so intellect is just one of them
intellect is very useful for survival
process because it gives you
discriminatory capability if you allow
you intellect to find out anything
suppose you want to know this flower
through your intellect you will see the
only thing you will do is pull it apart
and try to know it dissection is the way
of the intellect so if you want to know
your mother please don't dissect okay
that's not the way life happens if you
want an old life in its entirety you
need other dimensions of intelligence
because intellect has given ability to
survive and a certain sense of dominance
over others we have become devotees of
intellect intellect is a wonderful thing
no question about that
but you need to understand human
intellect functions only from the
limited data that it is gathered it
cannot explore anything entirely new you
can only project from what you know to
another dimension and you can never
project into an unknown dimension
through what you know right now that's
the reason why I would say Western
societies have been on a treadmill for a
long time they run a lot and they get
fit but they don't go anywhere
Fitness happens of course mm-hmm okay
now when we talk about human identity
and false association with certain
stereotypes why do we always strive to
to be a certain stereotype I mean why
does everybody in Pennsylvania want to
have a big house with a white picket
fence why is that the status of having
arrived because our
this is a society this idea of role
model is essentially from the West so a
few months ago I was being interviewed
by someone from here and this lady asked
me who is your role model set go
I said I don't roll with the models such
an idea never occurred to me it never
occurred to me how should I save myself
in Ho's image that never occurred to us
because the East is always looking at
how to turn inward and discover the
deeper potential in you never going out
to be like somebody else this is
something which is there in the natural
ethos of India that you cannot be
somebody else you can never ever be
someone else you can only be yourself
and how to make this yourself into your
full potential full-blown growth is all
the traditional yogic examples go like
this if a mango tree looks at a coconut
tree and thinks coconut tree is taller
and aspires to become a coconut tree it
will become a no-good mango tree so
every life is unique in its own way and
has its own place the only thing that
life has to do is to find the necessary
knowledge meant to get full-blown growth
if you become a full-blown yourself and
that's all you can do otherwise you will
become pretentious so the problem is
once once you go by your intellect these
two things are very connected once you
go over your intellect you will have a
whole lot of information but you don't
know anything this is modern education
you have a whole lot of information with
you everybody is rattling out what if in
a dinner party you can see people saying
exact distance between planet Earth and
blurry no planet Mars and everything but
what relevance is it it is just that you
can gather information like this when
you have information you have a false
sense of feeling that you know
everything but you know nothing
it may help you in the financial market
to have information but with life what
is needed is not information or
is needed is profoundness of purchase
that you have into life you need
traction into life experiencing life you
cannot know it if you read a book and
you think you know life or you figure
out something in your head and you think
you know it no you have to experience it
the profoundness of your experience is
what makes this life so if you go by the
intellect imitation is a natural process
and that's how the role models come can
I tell you story please I always seek
your permission because the moment I
start once upon a time a lot of people
think it's bedtime you know that's the
only time somebody told them a story so
this happened in early 20th century 1910
there was a man whose name was topi
Walla
Toby Walla means a hatzala you know
people second names indicate their trade
sometimes so he's going from village to
village town to town selling hats in the
tropical heat one afternoon he felt
tired and he went and sat down under a
tree opened his meager lunch ate and
dozed off after a little while he opened
his eyes and to his horror all the hats
were gone he looked all over the place
no hats when you you do everything
possible when you don't know what else
to do people pray so he looked up to
pray and he saw a bunch of monkeys
sitting there all hats on so he screamed
at them they screamed back at him he
abused them they abused in their own
language he picked up whatever he could
and threw it at them they picked up
whatever they couldn't throw it back at
him not knowing what to do out of sheer
frustration he took his hat and flung it
on the ground all the monkeys took their
heads and flung it on the ground and he
picked them up and went about his
business 2013 December 21st another man
was going around selling hats his name
also happens to be
- okie Walla and one afternoon event in
7:00 at a tree it is elaborate lunch
21st century you know and promptly fell
asleep after some time he woke up has
gone
he didn't look here and there he looked
straight up a bunch of monkeys were
sitting hats on he got up and jived
they all jived he made funny faces they
made funny faces he had all the fun he
wanted to have when he was done he
picked up his head and flung it on the
ground
a baboon of a monkey quickly came down
picked up the hat walked towards him
gave him a tight slap in the face and
said you idiot you think only you had a
grandfather so there is substantial
evidence there is evidence that monkeys
are evolving ok now once you go where
the limitations of your intellect you
are still a hunter and gatherer maybe
instead of gathering pieces of meat and
leather and bone and tooth of animals
today you gather information you know
the distance between Mars and Sun and
this and that
maybe you gather but still the nature of
the intellect is to gather by gathering
if you gather so much somebody who has
this much in front of that person in
comparison to that person you look
better but in the in the experience of
life you will not feel any better so if
you have gathered that much if somebody
has gathered this much then in front of
that person you feel like nothing so
gathering is always by comparison your
own gathering has no meaning it is only
in relation to somebody else's gathering
being more bigger than yours or in other
words in somewhere you start enjoying
somebody else's in capability or failure
or whatever so this is the nature of the
intellect because it survives on what
you have gathered
nevermind which will play a major role
Luigi way God effort or laugh or winning
election if you want to be innovation
tell all that is also faith God luck
effort maybe all of them but in what
proportion
so when you say fate obviously it's
something that you cannot do anything
about when you say luck again obviously
it's something that you cannot do
anything about when you say God again
it's something that you cannot do
anything about so only thing that's in
your hands is effort so put your 100%
into your effort what happens happens
the symptoms but don't leave proportions
of your energy and your capability to
luck God fate all these things that's
not your business if there is such a
thing it will act your business is only
effort something just do that effort has
to be incisive in the sense it should be
focused calibrated simply if you make
effort it's foolish effort isn't it just
labour is not going to get you somewhere
right kind of action the right timing
right place all this is important isn't
it so for all these things to happen you
need perception and intelligence so
that's all you must do in your life
constantly looking for ways to enhance
your perception and your intelligence
the rest will anyway happen
this is one thing that unfortunately
humanity is not doing they're trying to
become capable of something do not try
to become capable of something just
enhance your perception and intelligence
whatever comes your way right now let us
say it's like this you know this is
happening in the world all the time
everybody wants to become a doctor not
now if 25 years ago it was so you want
to study means first thing is medicine
if you don't get a seat what's next
engineering don't get a seat what next
thing next thing like this so let's say
you became a doctor and let us say
everybody came to the yoga program and
they stopped going to your doctor at
least your visits to the doctor has come
down isn't it has it has it come down or
no for sure
it's come down so business will go down
it will no more be a good profession to
go into because very few doctors are
becoming doctors because they want to
become doctors
others have becoming doctors because
they think it's lucrative isn't it isn't
it so most people are becoming doctors
because they think somebody's sickness
is a lucrative business it's a very I
don't want to go into other aspects it's
quite disturbing for me there are few
doctors who really want to be that they
want to understand the human system and
they want to serve in that direction
that's great
suppose everybody became healthy you
don't want that isn't it
yes you don't want that so do not try to
put up a recipe for your success success
is only when you are able to use
yourself to your full potential
it doesn't matter whether you become a
doctor or politician or a yogi or what
the hell you become is not the thing
success means you are living your life
to your full potential that's what
success means if that has to happen you
need perception and an active
intelligence how do I grow my
intelligence don't worry about that
right now the important thing is to
enhance your perception if you are able
to see life just the way it is you have
the necessary intelligence to conduct it
well if you are not able to see life the
way it is your intelligence will work
against you most intelligent people on
this planet are generally the most
miserable people on the planet this is
simply because they have an active
intelligence but no perception of life
so one thing one most important thing
that people have not worked at is to
enhance their perception they're trying
to broaden their mind that's not the
point that will only make you socially
successful not truly successful if you
want to be truly successful you must be
able to see everything just the way it
is without distortions if you can see
everything just the way it is life
becomes a play you can play joyfully you
can play it well for sure if you can
play it well people will say you're
successful you should never think I want
to be successful don't ever think I want
to be successful just see how to make
this being your full-fledged
being
people will say one day oh he's
successful he's a great success you
should not be aspiring for success it's
a miserable way to structure your life
but every human being should start the
process of turning inward otherwise when
moment of death comes all you will have
is belief systems to hang on to and
everything that you believe everything
that you think matters to you right now
will not matter to you if the next
moment is death and I'm sorry to remind
you but anyway you will die it's not my
wish I will bless you with a long life
but anyway you will die
is it okay you need to understand this
is the fundamental of turning inward
that you realize that your motto you
realize that you have come with an
expiry date
you realize you're racing towards it if
you remind yourself of this how can you
not look at life more profoundly how can
you only because you think you are here
forever
you can forget about it it doesn't
matter what you think you think you come
to the top you think you're going to go
home you think you're going to this
place of that place but as far as your
body is concerned it is walking straight
to the grave yes or no
you think so many things this is all
your nonsense but the reality is your
body is walking straight to the grave
not missing a step
yes or no will bless you with a long
life but if you understand and if you
constantly conscious that I am mato
there is no way you cannot look at
deeper dimensions of life you'll
naturally we'll just a quick notice you
guys watch listen to this video is sad
guru says something that really
resonates with you put it in the
comments below with quotes around the
outside so we can keep track of what you
really resonate with thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I
love to know your thoughts in this video
did you like it did a move you which
clip resonated the most with you leaving
the comments below and I will join the
discussion also those people who've been
leaving quotes from this video if
there's some that really resonate with
you give it a thumbs up and show some
love finally I want to give a quick
shout out to our terrible baya our tool
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book really means a lot to me for
those of you watching if you want your
chains at a shadow in a future video
make sure to grab a copy of the book and
also email in the receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching to continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon